ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคือ
เรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนใช้เก้าอี้ผู้
กำกับค่ะครูผ้ากับทุเรียนอีกแล้วนะคะค่ะ
ที่ไหนคะครูป่าอันนี้ที่วีดีโอ Dinner นะ
มีทั้งสี
แดงสีนักเรียนวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยเรา
มาต่อจากวีดีโอที่แล้วใช่ไหมว่าวีดีโอที่
แล้วเนี่ยครูฟ้าเล่าเรื่องนะคะเป็นนิทาน
นิทานของไทยเรื่องพิกุลทอง
ใช้แหล่งยังไม่จบนาวีดีโอนี้ก็เลยเป็น
เหมือน EP2 นะคะนักเรียนถ้า
ใครยังไม่ได้ดูวีดีโอที่แล้วนักเรียนไปดู
วีดีโอที่แล้วก่อนใช่ไหมครับให้ค่ะไปดู
พี่คุณทอง Ep  1 ก่อนนะคะทุกคน
ข้อใดต่อมาถึงตอนนี้จำได้ว่า
เราอยู่ที่บนเรือมีแล้วทุกคนบนเรือก็ถูก
แล้งกิน kin ๆกินไปหมดแล้วเหลือเหลือ
พิกุลทองเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองอยู่คนเดียวน่า
อยู่แค่คนเดียวนะคะที่นี่เนี่ยพิกุลทอง
เนี่ยก็ลงไปหลบอยู่ข้างล่างใช่ไหมแอบอยู่
ไม่ให้ใครเห็นแน่นอนว่า
แร้งเดียวก็มองไม่เห็นอ้ะ
แบงค์ก็บินหาเลยว่า
คนไหนคือเจ้าหญิงพิกุลคนไหน
เจ้าหญิงพิกุลในเวลาผู้ต้องมีดอกพิกุล
ร่วงออกมาข้อไหนใช่คนไหนคือเจ้าหญิงพิกุล
แรงทุกตัวก็ช่วยกันหาหาไม่เจอค่ะคุณ
เอี่ยม
แล้วเขาไม่ไม่มาหาแบบขอให้ท้องเรือใช่หา
เขาไม่ได้มาหาข้างใต้ฮาๆๆไม่มีหาไม่มีแรง
ไม่ได้มาหาใต้ท้องเรือแย้งก็เลยเหมือน
ทะเลาะกันว่าแกกินเจ้าหญิงพิกุลไปใช่ไหม
แรง a และ b และเอกก็กินผู้หญิงที่คุณไว้
ใช่ไหมครั้งบีก็ฉันไม่ได้กินแกนั่นแหละ
กินทะเลาะกันไอ้กินเจ้าหญิงไปบอกมาเดี๋ยว
นี้ก็คือมันไม่มีใครรู้ไม่มีแรงตัวไหนรู้
เลยว่าเจ้าหญิงอยู่ที่ไหน
แร้งก็เลยทำยังไงล่ะก็ต้องกลับดินกับไป
อ่าละของคิดไหมว่าแบบเจ้าหญิงน่ะตายไป
แล้วก็เป็นไปได้เจ้าหญิงอาจจะตายไปแล้วก็
ได้แรงไม่รู้ไงแรงพรุ่งนี้ก็เลยบินกลับไป
นะเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยเขาอยู่ข้างล่างแล้วก็คิด
จะทำยังไงดี
อ่าเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะนางฟ้าที่ดูแลเจ้าหญิง
เนี่ยนางฟ้าเนี่ยมันก็บอกว่าใช่นางฟ้าก็
บอกว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยไม่มีแรงแล้วขึ้นมาข้าง
บนได้อ่าก็อยู่ข้างล่างนานๆออกซิเจนมัน
นิดหน่อยใช่ไหมให้เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยขึ้นมา
ข้างบนได้แล้วก็จะไม่มีแรงตัวไหนมาที่
เรือนี้ภายใน 7 วัน
โห
ไม่มีแรงผู้หญิงก็อยู่คนเดียวบนเรือเจ็ด
วางเหรอคะเจ้าหญิงก็ต้องอยู่ค่ะก็หญิงก็
คิดเออฉันจะทำยังไงดีหน้าฉันจะพายเรือกับ
ไปก็ไม่ใช่เพราะว่าเรือหลังใหญ่มั้ง
เจ้าหญิงไม่ทำอะไรไม่ได้ค่ะก็ต้องอยู่ที่
เรือนี้จริงก็เลยคิดว่า
ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็
ถ้าเอาผมตัวเองเนี่ยออกมา
เอาผมออกมา 1 เส้นให้นักเรียน 1 เส้นพอนะ
จะเอามาเยอะนะเจ้าหญิงก็หยิบผมมา 1 เส้น
แล้วก็
คิดมาคิดหาเราบอกว่าอธิษฐานใช่ไหมอธิษฐาน
เหมือนเวลาที่นักเรียนเนี่ย Happy
Birthday นะวันเกิดด้วยคะฝรั่งก็น่าจะ
เหมือนกันเวลามีวันเกิดและมีเค้กก่อนที่
เราจะเป่าแล้วก็จะอธิษฐานขอให้มีเงินเยอะ
ๆขอให้อ่าไอ้คิวดีขอให้แข็งแรง
นี้คือการอธิษฐาน
เจ้าหญิงก็อธิษฐานขอให้ไอคิวดีใช่ไหมคะ
อุ้ย
อ่าขอให้แข็งแรงขอให้แข็งแรงไม่ใช่เองนี่
หั่นอะไรก็หญิงเนี่ยหยิบเส้นผมเอามาแล้ว
ก็อธิษฐานว่า
แต่ถ้าเกิดใครที่เป็น
คนรักของฉันจริงๆขอให้เส้นผมอันนี้ขอให้
เส้นผมเนี่ยไปหาผู้ชายที่เป็นคนรักของฉัน
จริงๆหรือว่าเนื้อคู่นะคะเนื้อคู่ก็คือ
เหมือนเป็นคนที่ต้องแต่งงานการอะไรเงี้ย
อาจจะยังไม่รู้จักกันใช่ไหมเนื้อคู่ระลึก
เนื้อคู่กูฝาเส้นผมนะเส้นผม 1 เส้นแล้ว
อธิษฐานเสร็จแล้วเอาไปไหนคะอะที่หาญเสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยเจ้าหญิงก็เหมือนมีกล่องนะกล่อง
กล่องสี่เหลี่ยมหมอนก็มีกล่องนะคะ
จากนั้นเราก็นี่กล่องใหญ่ผู้หญิงอาจจะใส่
กล่องเล็กๆนะคะนักเรียน
ก็เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็เอาเส้นผมเนี่ยใส่กล่อง
แล้วก็ก็ขอให้เนื้อคู่ของฉันเจอเส้นผม
แล้วก็ขอให้มาช่วยฉันด้วยเออแล้วก็เขียน
จดหมายไว้เขียนจะมีปากกาและเขียนใส่
กระดาษ
ขอให้มาช่วยฉันด้วยแล้วก็เอาใส่ไปในกล่อง
แล้วก็เอากล่องใส่ในทะเลนะคะอ๋อลงไปใน
ทะเลอะลงไปในทวิตมากเจ้าหญิงแบบอธิษฐาน
แล้วก็เอาผมลงไปในทะเลหรือเปล่าก็เลยแบบ
ไม่น่าจะมีใครมาเจอแล้วจะไม่เจอนะเพราะผม
เส้นผมแล้วมันเล็กมากใช่ไหมถ้าได้ก็เลย
เอาใส่ก็ยังใหม่อยู่ที่ใส่กรอบชายแล้ว
กล่องนี้เนี่ยก็ลอยไปหาลอยไปในทะเลนะลอย
ไปลอยไปลอยไปลอยไปจนกระทั่งกล่องเนี้ย
รอยไปที่เมืองเมืองหนึ่ง
เป็นเมืองเลยนะครับเมือง
นี้มือนี้เนี่ยก็มีพระราชาและก็มีเจ้าชาย
นายไทยนะถ้าเราชายแล้วอ่ะคนละเมืองกับ
เมืองพิกุลเนาะ
อะราชาใช้แล้วก็มีเจ้าชายจะชายนี้ก็เป็น
ผู้ชายที่หล่อมากใช่ไหมผู้ชายนะฮะซึ่ง
เจ้าชายเนี่ยก็วันนั้นจะชายบอกมาเดินเล่น
ที่ทะเลจะเห็นกล่องนะเนี่ยลอยมา
ใช้คิดเองกล่องอะไรนะ
อยู่ลอยมาอยู่แถวนี้ได้ยังไงก็เลยหยิบ
กล่องนี้ขึ้นมาเราก็เปิดดูข้างไหน
มีเส้นผมหล่อนึกว่าเปิดออกมานะไม่มีอะไร
เลยมีอะไรล่ะมีเส้นผมแล้วล่ะถ้าไอ้หัวป่า
ก์
คุณแม่คะผู้ขายก็สนใจว่าเปิดออกมาแล้ว
เห็นเส้นผมถึงเส้นกูว่าจะมองไม่เห็นด้วย
นะคะไม่ใช่
รถมาไม่ดีเส้นผมเล็กมากแต่นักเรียนจำได้
ไหมว่าเส้นผมของพิกุลเนี่ยไม่ใช่เส้นผม
ธรรมดาว่าพี่กุลเนี่ยมีผมที่หอมใช่ไหมหอม
มากเพราะฉะนั้นเจ้าชายก็หยิบเส้นผมนี้
ขึ้นมาแล้วก็ผมของใครทำไมหอมขนาดนี้
ของตลาดนี้
แล้วรู้สึกเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรอ้ะรัก
รักเส้นหอมใช่ประชาคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้
เนี่ยจะต้องเป็นเนื้อคู่ของฉันจะต้องเป็น
คนที่ฉันรักมากๆแน่ๆเลยแต่ไม่รู้ว่าใครนะ
หนูจะใช้อ่านไหมอ่านกระดาษมั้ยใช่มาแล้ว
หยิบกระดาษขึ้นมาแล้วรู้สึก
สงสารหนูสงสารคือแบบอุ้ย
ผู้หญิงต้องการความช่วยเหลือใช่มั้ยก็เลย
คิดว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยเราต้องเป็นคนรักของ
ฉันฉันจะต้องรักเธอมากๆและฉันต้องไปช่วย
เธอให้ได้ชายก็เลยกลับบ้านไปบอกคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่ผมจะไปช่วยผู้หญิงของผมครับพ่อแม่ก็
ใครลูกปิ้งของลูกคือใครผมไม่รู้แต่เธอคิด
ว่าผมผมกับผมนะในเรื่องมึงผมแล้วก็คงแล้ว
ก็ผมอ่ะเล่นบุ๋มของผมไปเจอเส้นผมมาแล้ว
มันหอมมากเลยแล้วผมรู้สึกว่าผู้หญิงนี้
เนี่ยจะต้องเป็นคนรักของผมแล้วก็ผมต้องไป
ช่วยเธอให้ได้
ผู้ชายก็เลยออกไปค่ะ
เขาเรียกว่าออกเรือไปเลยขึ้นเรือสายก็มี
เรือเหมือนกันก็ขึ้นเรือขับไปอ่ะอยู่
ระหว่างทางที่กำลังไปนะคะ
ผู้ชายก็
เอเชียเหมือนอ่านจดหมายจะใช้ก็อ่านจดหมาย
กระดาษเนาะอย่าคิดว่ากูคิดว่าเขาน่าจะ
อ่านนิดหน่อยลื่นอ้าวทำไมคะทำไมถึงคิดว่า
อ่านนิดหน่อยเพราะว่าเจ้าชายเนี่ยไปเจอ
เกาะเกาะหนึ่งนะคะก่อนเกาะใช่แล้วค่ะ
เรียบเป็นเกาะ
แล้วก็ออกนะเนี่ยก็มีผู้หญิงคนนึงอยู่ที่
เกาะอยากมีผู้หญิงคนเดียวหรอคะอยู่ที่
เกาะใช่ค่ะเจ้าชายเนี่ยอ่านกระดาษแล้วก็
คิดว่าเฮ้ยในกระดาษเนี่ยบอกไว้ว่าเจ้า
หญิงพิกุลเนี่ยอยู่คนเดียว
ที่เกาะนี้ก็มีผู้หญิงอยู่คนเดียวเหมือน
กันและเป็นผู้หญิงที่สวยด้วยใช่หรือเปล่า
มีผู้ชายก็เลยเอาเรือเนี่ยมาจอดที่เกาะ
แล้วก็เดินลงไป
แต่จริงๆแล้วผู้หญิงคนนี้ไม่ใช่เจ้าหญิง
พิกุลทองค่ะโคเรียมอ้าวชายรู้ได้ยังไงคะ
ผู้ชายยังไม่รู้อะเนี่ยฟ้าแอบมองคนเลี้ยง
ก่อน
ไม่ใช่หานักเรียนจะผู้หญิงคนนี้ไม่ใช่
เจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองแต่ผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็น
ยักษ์เห้ย
เป็นยักษ์ยักษ์พี่กินคนหานักเรียนมาเอา
อ้าซึ่งจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยยักษ์ตัวเนี้ยนะ
รู้ว่า
เจ้าชายเนี่ยกำลังจะมาแล้วอยากในก็รู้สึก
วิเจ้าชายหล่อจังแล้วรู้สึกโง่รักชายมากๆ
เพราะเห็นเจ้าชายก็เลยรับยักษ์ตัวนี้ก็
เลยเปลี่ยนจากยักษ์ใช้ที่น่ากลัวนะคะ
ยักษ์มาเป็นผู้หญิงและพิสูจน์สวยก็อยู่
ที่เกาะนี้พระเอิร์นว่าเจ้าชายนะเห็นแล้ว
จะชายก็วิวิน่าจะเป็นเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองใช่
ไหมจะฉายก็เลยเดินเข้ามาคุยด้วย
เราคุยด้วยก็แล้วเสร็จแล้วก็
ยังอยู่ด้วยกันเถอะกินโดยชายเนี่ย
ยักษ์ว่าเขารักก็เนาะเค้ารักค่ะเขาไม่กิน
เจ้าชายแต่ว่าน้องชายค่ะพี่กุณท้องอยู่บน
เรือค่ะนี่ก็ต้องยูโรค่ะถ้าอยากพิกุลทอง
ก็บอกว่าฉันอยู่บนเรือแต่ก็ชายไม่ได้อ่าน
มาแล้วใช้ไม่เก่งภาษาไทยนะคะเข้ามาดิฉัน
อะไรเดียวขอถ้าเยอะๆเฮ้ย
มันไม่อ่านภาษาไทยก็เลยได้อยู่กับยักษ์
ที่เกาะนี้แล้วก็เป็นสามีภรรยากัน
ทรายต้องทองพี่ดูไม่เข้าญี่ปุ่นเรือก็เคย
อยู่นะ
ว่าใหม่นะผู้ชายค่ะที่
อยู่ยักษ์แล้วค่ะแต่ด้วยความที่ว่าเจ้า
ชายเนี่ยก็จะมีเรื่องอะไรอ่ะเหมือนก็อยู่
กับอยากไปประมาณก็คิดว่าจะหนึ่งวันสองวัน
สามวันแล้วจะประมาณ 3 วันหนึ่งเป็นสามี
ภรรยากันแล้วนะคะอยู่ในกัน 3 วันเสร็จ
แล้วเจ้าชายเนี่ยก็มีเหมือนเครียกว่า
เหมือนนางฟ้าเหมือนกันพิกุลทองว่ามีนาง
ฟ้าใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
น้องฟ้ามาทำอะไรคะ
ก็ชายแล้วก็มีนางฟ้าเนี่ยเหมือนมาพูดให้
ได้ยินว่านี่ไม่ใช่เจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
นี่ผู้หญิงคนนี้เป็นหยัง
วุ้ยยักษ์ตกใจไหมคะเจ้าชาย
What ให้แล้วไม่ได้รายการถ่ายงงมากก็ก็
เลยทำไงดีล่ะไม่งั้น
เจ้าชายก็มีเวทมนตร์เหมือนกันค่ะ
แม่ก็ชายช้าไปไหมคุณใช่วันสองวันผ่านไป
แล้วนะเจ้าชายไปสุดท้ายก็เลยใช้เวทมนตร์
เนี่ย
ทำให้ยักษ์หลับ
น้ำเอางูชักก็หลับไปพอยักษ์หลับไปแล้ว
เดี๋ยวจะใช้ก็เลยแอบออกมาจากเกาะนี้นะคะ
แล้วก็ขึ้นเรือไป
ไปให้เจอพี่คุณทองนี่ฮะระหว่างที่ขึ้น
เรือไปเนี่ยบอกว่าเขาบอกว่าจะชายในใช้
เวลาเดินทาง 7 วัน
หน้าขอบครบ 7 วันเจ้าชายก็มาถึงพอดีและ
เห็นพิกุลน่ะเห็นเรือก่อนเป็นเรือใหญ่ๆ
แล้วก็มีคนตายเต็มไปหมดหน้าก็ก็เห็นผู้
หญิงมากใช่มีพิกุลอยู่แล้วใช้ก็เลยคิดว่า
ค่ะวันนี้แหละต้องเป็นเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทอง
แน่นอนพอดีกับที่พญาแล้งนะคะกลับมาเพื่อ
ที่จะเช็คดูว่าเจ้าหญิงที่คุณอยู่ไหน
ก็เลยเจ้าชายมาพอดีและพญาแรงก็มาพอดีแน่
นอนว่าจะชายเป็นพระเอกนักเรียนหรือเจ้า
ชายก็คือผู้ชายเนาะก็เลยสู้กับพญาแล้ง
ทุ่งกันหากเตรียมสุดท้ายแล้วพระเอกก็ต้อง
ชนะเตรียมเช่นถูกไหม
skill นะเป็นสกิลพระเอกหนังนี่ไงก็เป็น
เจ้าชายไงก็เลยชนะสู้กาญจน์ชนะพญาแรงไป
เจ้าชายก็เลยขึ้นมาเจอกับเจ้าหญิงพิกุล
แล้วก็ก็คุยกันว่าเป็นยังไงบ้างเธอโอเค
ไหมถึงอยู่นะเพราะว่าจะโอเคผู้ชายก็เลยพา
เจ้าหญิงที่คุณเนี่ยนั่งเรือกลับเมืองไป
ด้วยกัน
กลับไปผู้ชายนะคะแล้วก็แต่งงานกัน
ร้านแต่งงานกันแล้วเรื่องนี้ก็จบ
หรือเปล่าจบดีไหมคะ
นี่แต่งงานกันแล้วนะคะลูกค้าคือชายกับ
เจ้าหญิงก็แต่งงานแต่งงานเรียบร้อยแล้ว
แต่งงานเรียบร้อยแล้วฮะแต่ว่าต้องบอก
เรียนก่อนว่านิทานไทยนักเรียน
นักเรียนดู 1 เดือนก็คงไม่จบอ่ะคือ
หนังสือที่อ่านของไทยเนี่ยหนังสือเล่มขณะ
นี้นั้น
หนามากเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันก็จะมี
เวอร์ชั่นที่ยาวกว่านี้นะคะซึ่งจริงๆแล้ว
เนี่ยมันยังไม่จบ
แต่ว่าไม่มีเวลาอีกไหม
ใช่ไหมเรามาเจอกันตั้งแต่ตอนประมาณบ่าย 2
52 น
ตอนนี้ 3:00 นนิภา 39 นาทีอ่ะ
ro89 มาบวกเลขบวกเลขตรงนี้เลยได้ห้ามดู
นะคะมีประวัติเลข 3  4 นาทีค่ะครูฟ้าไม่
ทันค่ะเอาเป็นว่า
ก็นักเรียนมันมีอยู่เวอร์ชั่นที่ยาวกว่า
นี้ซึ่งจริงๆเนี่ยที่หาญเรื่องนี้เนี่ย
มันก็มีหลายเวอร์ชั่นนักเรียนถ้านักเรียน
สนใจที่หาเรื่องพิกุลทองรถไปเสิร์ชใน
อินเทอร์เน็ตนั่นเองอาจจะเจอเยอะมากหลาย
เวอร์ชั่นมากๆเลยนะคะก็จะมีบางเวอร์ชั่น
ที่มันจบแบบ Happy  Ending ตรงนี้เลยแล้ว
ก็มีเวอร์ชั่นที่ยาววันนี้
ซึ่งออกถ้านักเรียนอยากฟังเล่นก็
คอมเม้นต์ไว้ได้ว่านั้นอยากฟังเวอร์ชั่น
นี้ต่อกูมาเล่าให้ฟังต่อได้ไหมเออว่าหลัง
จากนี้เจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองกับชายที่แต่งงาน
กันแล้วเนี่ยเป็นยังไง
ใช่ใช่ไหมรู้สึกว่าเฮ้ยทำไมนิทานไทยถึงมา
นะฮะคะอันนี้ขอพูดหลังจากที่แบบจบกันตรง
นี้ก่อนไหวนิทานไทยถึงมากสัตว์เหมือนแร้ง
อ่ะพูดกับคนได้แล้วทำใหม่เจ้าชายถึงต้อง
มีเหมือนเวทมนตร์อะไรเงี้ยหมดคือคนไทย
เนี่ยจะเชื่อเรื่องเวทย์มนต์มากๆเลยนะ
มนต์ไหนเนี่ยนะฮะคือเราคิดว่าเมื่อก่อนนะ
น้องเมื่อก่อนอาจจะมีการอาจจะมีเวทมนตร์
น่าจะมีอะไรที่ทำให้สัตว์เปลี่ยนเป็นคน
หรือว่าคนเปลี่ยนเป็นสัตว์ก็ได้
มันคือพญาแรงใช่ไหมใช้เวทมนต์แล้วก็
เปลี่ยนให้เป็นคนมีอะๆถ้าคุณเหมียวด้วยรอ
ด้วยจ้ะทำได้ยังไงนะคะจะให้จริงแต่เรา
เหม็นแค่นั้นแหละเราสิคือมันก็มีเวทมนตร์
จะทำได้เป็นบางอย่างซึ่งนี้ทันทีอะไร
เรื่องก็จะเป็นอย่างนี้แหละส่วนใหญ่จะมี
เป็นเวทย์มนต์นะคะอ่ะทั้งหมดเฉลี่ยใหญ่
เนาะเราพระเอกนะก็ต้องเป็นคนที่แบบเวลา
สู้ๆก็จะชนะรู้คนชนะเพราะเป็นพระเอกดูจาก
แบบนิทานของประเทศอื่นๆก็เหมือนกัน
ใช่ปลาที่ไหลทุกคนก็ตายจากพระเอกก็ยังแบบ
โอเคโอเคนะฮะพระเอกคือเจ้าชายเนาะเราบอก
ว่านิทานเรื่องเนี่ยพระเอกคือเจ้าชายส่วน
นางเอกก็คือเจ้าหญิงพิกุลทองให้พระเอก
นิทานหลายๆเรื่องก็จะมีนะคะใช่อยู่ที่ว่า
นักเรียนอยากจะฟังต่อรึเปล่าเพราะว่า
เตรียมจำได้ว่าพิกุลทองเนี่ยเวลาพูดจะมี
ดอกพิกุลที่คุณท้องที่กุลบอกเวลาพูดจะมี
ดอกพิกุลทองร่วงออกมาจากป่าใช่โอ้น้องมัน
คงแปลกดีนะคะที่เวลาคนเราพูดน้องเรามีดอก
พิกุลเอามาจากปากนะในนิทานเหมือนกันน่ะ
เขามองว่ามันเป็นเรื่องดีใช่ไหมคะใช่เหอะ
เรียมนิทานละครลองลองนึกถึงชีวิตจริงๆที่
เวลาเราพูดแล้วก็แบบร็อคๆๆ
ดอกไม้เอาไว้ตลอดเวลาถึงทุกวันก็คิดว่า
เราจะรวยก็ตามนะคะมันก็แปะดี
ครูฟ้ากำลังกินข้าวอยู่สมมติว่าหูฟ้ามี
ดอกพิกุลออกมาเรียนก็ถามผู้ฟ้าอร่อยไหม
อร่อยมากเลยค่ะครูเตรียมอาหารที่มันอร่อย
ค่ะนี้เราบอกคุณก็หล่นเต็มข้าวแล้วยังไง
ใช่ก็เลิกไปกินข้าวต่อได้ยังไงใช่ไหมงั้น
ใช่ใช่แต่มันก็คือนิทานอ่ะเนาะแต่มันก็
คือนิทานนะคะนักเรียนก็เลยเป็นประมาณนี้
นะคะวันนี้ถ้านักเรียนอยากฟังต่อก็
คอมเม้นต์ไว้ได้เวอร์ชั่นที่ยาวกว่านี้
แต่ว่าอะไรแล้วเร็วสึกว่าแค่นี้พอแล้ว
แหละ Happy  Ending ก็
จะไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวจะมีเรื่องแบบเบจยังไม่
มาอีกเหรอเดี๋ยวเราก็เฮ้ยนี่มาไล่อะไรอีก
มีอีกนักเรียนจริงแล้วเนี่ยนานถ้าอยากฟัง
หรือยังไงก็คอมเม้นท์ไม่ได้ค่ะใช้อะไรหมด
เวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะใช่แล้วค่ะ
เจอกันค่ะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะขอเรียน
นี้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่ว่าวายส์